l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi pour le plein
emploi la parole est à Monsieur Paul
Christophe rapporteur de la commission
mixte
paritaire merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur chers collègues après 80h de
débat dans notre assemblée j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter en tant que
rapporteur mais également au nom de ma
collègue corrapporteur Madame Christine
lenabour le texte issu des travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire réunit le 23
octobre et adopté par le Sénat jeudi
dernier députés et sénateurs se sont
attachés à enrichir le projet de loi qui
vise à rénover l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi dans un contexte de
baisse du chômage favoriser l'insertion
sur le méchar du travail des personnes
en situation de handicap et améliorer la
gouvernance de l'accueil du jeune enfant
les discussions ont été nourries
franches parfois passionnées mais j'ai
la conviction qu'elles nous ont permis
d'adopter un texte reposant sur des
solutions pragmatiques conçu dans une
perspective clairement assumée atteindre
le plein emploi la première pierre du
projet de loi inscrite à l'article 1er
est la transformation de la nature même
de la liste des demandeurs d'emploi qui
devient un outil d'accompagnement de
l'ensemble des personnes sans emploi
àocataire de l'assurance chômage ou
bénéficier du RSA l'ambition portée par
le projet de loi se traduit aussi à
l'article 2 par une meilleure définition
des objectifs de chaque demandeur
d'emploi ainsi que des moyens pour y
parvenir ainsi demain le bénéficiaire du
RSA et son référent pourront ensemble
fixer des objectifs progressifs afin de
construire de nouvelles perspectives
professionnelles mais aussi lever les
freins périphériques rencontrés nous
sommes parvenus à une rédaction de
compromis après de longs débats dans
chacune de nos assemblées s'agissant de
la mise en œuvre du plan d'action si les
sénateurs ont ajouté une obligation
d'activité d'au moins 15 heur par
semaine nous avons prévu des cas de
minoration voire
d'exemption l'article 3 construit un
régime de sanction plus progressif par
la création d'une sanction intermédiaire
dite de suspension remobilisation avec
la possibilité d'un reversement
rétroactif dans la limite de 3 mois le
titre 2 du projet de loi propose une
nouvelle organisation du service public
de l'emploi l'article 4 crée le réseau
pour l'emploi réunissant l' des acteurs
de l'emploi de la formation et de
l'insertion afin de définir un nouveau
cadre de coopération ainsi le texte que
nous vous proposons d'adopter repose sur
un équilibre entre coopération renforcée
et respect des compétences de chacun
jusqu'au bassin d'emploi s'agissant du
Comité national nous avons recherché un
équilibre entre représentativité et
prise de décisions efficace si la
question du nom de l'opérateur principal
du service public de l'emploi a été un
point de discussion à l'article 5 je me
félicite du compromis trouvé quantre à
la transformation de Pôle emploi en
opérateur France travail nécessaire à
l'impulsion d'une nouvelle dynamique au
sein du réseau pour l'emploi les
articles 6 et 7 constituent des briques
supplémentaires dans notre stratégie en
faveur du plein emploi à destination des
puques les plus fragiles ou en besoin de
formation supplémentaires tout comme les
articles 4 10 d et 7 bis insérés par
notre assemblée l'article 11 permettra
de s'assurer de la bonne application à
l'ensemble du territoire y compris
lesromèes des principes de ce projet de
loi j'en viens à présent au titre 3 et
je tiens à saluer à cette occasion le
travail réalisé par ma collègue
Christine lenabour ce titre rassemble un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
tendent à favoriser l'accès à l'emploi
et le maintien en emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap dans le
prolongement des précédentes réformes
portées notamment par la loi du 5
septembre 2018 pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel
l'article 8 enrichit la législation sur
plusieurs points je ne les mentionnerai
pas tous mais pour autant il est temp à
ensemble des bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi des travailleuxs
handicapés l'application des dispositifs
ouverts au seuls travailleurs reconnu
handicapés par la CDAPH il supprime le
principe de l'orientation de ces
travailleurs en milieu ordinaire pour
qu'elle devienneent l'orientation de
droit commun et il pérénise les
dispositifs expérimentaux relatifs au
CDD tremplin et aux Entreprises Adaptées
de travail temporaire les eatt l'article
9 traduit quelques-unes des annonces
faites lors de la dernière conférence
nationale du handicap en particulier
celle consistant à faire les droits
individuels et collectifs des
travailleurs accueillis en NAT vers ceux
qui sont reconnus aux salariés j'en
viens pour terminer au disposition du
titre 4 l'article 10 fait des communes
les autorités organisatrices de la
politique d'accueil du jeune enfant et
les charges entre autres de remplir
plusieurs missions le recensement des
modes d'accueil et des besoins des
familles d'enfants de moins de 3 ans ou
l'information et l'accompagnement des
familles seul les communes de plus de
10000 habitants sont tenus d'élaborer un
schéma pluriannuel de maintien et de
développ
de l'offre d'accueil du jeune enfant
ainsi que de mettre en place un relais
petite enfance 10 RPE les nouvelles
obligations prisons-le un combat aux
communes entreront en vigueur pour
l'essentiel le 1er janvier 2025 enfin
l'article 10 bis rénove en profondeur le
régime de l'inspection et du contrôle
des établissements d'accueil du jeune
enfant ce qui apparaît indispensable au
regard des carences de la législation
actuelle et de la situation observée sur
le terrain bien décrite par Ligas dans
son rapport de mars dernier je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier duop ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de
[Applaudissements]
l'insertion merci madame la présidente
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame et monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés le gouvernement accueille avec
une grande satisfaction l'accord trouvé
entre l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
en commission mixte par paritaire
puisque cet accord permet de terminer
l'examen d'un projet de loi majeur pour
notre pays la procédure législative
s'est montrée à la hauteur par des
débats parlementaires de grande qualité
aussi bien à l'Assemblée qu'au Sénat et
je tiens à remercier l'ensemble des
parlementaires pour leur travail
méticuleux qui débouche ainsi sur un
compromis d'intérêt général à ce titre
je veux saluer particulièrement
l'engagement constant exigeant des deux
rapporteurs madame la députée Len bour
et Monsieur le Député christop ainsi que
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales madame Parmentier leco
ce texte ambitieux ce texte libré doit
beaucoup à cette forte implication
parlementaire ex exercé je crois dans un
esprit de de responsabilité qui honore
le Parlement les disposition de ce
projet de loi crée de nouveaux outils
pour progresser vers un objectif central
le plein le plein emploi pour tous et le
plein emploi partout c'est notre
objectif majeur le président de la
République a fixé cette ambition et nous
mettons tout en œuvre pour l'atteindre
c'est à la fois un objectif collectif
pour notre économie et nos territoire
mais aussi une quête d'émancipation
individuelle par le travail pour la
liberté la dignité de chacun sur T les
ban vous connaissez les constats qui ont
mené le gouvernement à l'élaboration de
ce projet de loi en premier lieu il
s'agit de résoudre le paradoxe
d'entreprise qui peinent à recruter
alors même que le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi reste important il y a aussi
cette conviction qui irigue le texte
celle que personne n'est inemployable et
que nous que nous pouvons parvenir à
l'inclusion de ceux que la vie a éloigné
du marché du travail si nous prévoyons
l'accompagnement la formation et les
outils d'incertion nécessaire c'est pour
ces deux raisons que le projet de loi
propose un saut qualitatif dans
l'accompagnement vers l'emploi
par une meilleure formalisation par une
approche plus personnalisée il doit
permettre d'améliorer l'accompagnement
de ceux qui font face à des difficultés
particulières qu'il soit en situation de
handicap ou bien à locataire du RSA en
effet je tiens à le rappeler devant vous
le texte prévoit des mesures fortes
concernant l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap je pense notamment
à l'instauration d'un droit universel à
l'orientation en milieu ordinaire appuyé
par un projet professionnel mieux
accompagné par le service public de
l'emploi de même pour n'exclure plus
aucun demandeur d'emploi le texte
prévoit notamment l'inscription
systématique auprès de France travail
des allocataires du RSA c'est donc pour
cela dans une logique de droit et de
devoir que nous créons le contrat
d'engagement adosser un meilleur
accompagnement du bénéficiaire et qui
s'articule avec un régime de contrôle
dont les sanctions se veulent davantage
progressives mais surtout plus
effectives depuis le printemps dernier
pour ce qui concerne les allocataires du
RSA 18 départements mènent une
expérimentation de ce dispositif les
retours de terrain sont très
encourageants avec des chiffres
prometteurs d'entré en parcours
d'accompagnement évidemment des données
plus plus précises plus complètes sont
en cours de fiabilisation notamment
celles relative à la nature des
orientations au taux de satisfaction des
bénéficiaires et dès qu'elles seront
stabilisées nous les partagerons
évidemment avec le Parlement mesdames et
messieurs les députés je veux aussi
souligner devant vous que ces mesures au
service d'un meilleur accompagnement
vers l'emploi c'est d'abord un devoir de
la collectivité auprès des demandeurs
d'emploi à forceie lorsquil se heurent à
des difficultés particulières c'est
aussi l'assurance d'un meilleur retour
vers l'emploi pour tous et une condition
pour que tous les conseillers en
insertion professionnelle puissent
trouver plus de sens à leur action
je souhaite aussi souligner que pour
contenir les tensions de recrutement
notre deuxième grand défi le deuxième
grand défi auquel s'attaque le texte
c'est de proposer une meilleure offre de
service aux entreprises notamment à
destination des plus petites qui n'ont
pas aujourd'hui les instruments pour
faire face à des difficultés lié au
problématique de ressources humaines
enfin c'est notre trème objectif nous
voulons réformer la gouvernance du
service public de l'emploi comme une
réponse à l'éclatement dont il souffrre
nous voulons favoriser la coordination
des acteurs par une gouvernance
renforcée à tous les échelons
territoriaux désormais l'État et les
collectivités ainsi que les partenaires
sociaux travailleront de concert avec
les opérateurs et les partenaires du
réseau pour pour faire converger les
politiques menés ensemble ça n'est ni ni
une centralisation ni une subordination
cachée mais bien une meilleure
coopération et un vrai partage des
données bien sûr toutes ces ambitions
appellent des moyens des moyens
renforcés c'est pourquoi vous le savez
le projet de loi de finance pour 2024
prévoit notamment la mobilisation de 300
millions d'euros pour la mise en œuvre
de la réforme le plafond d'emploi de
l'opérateur France travail sera
reéhaussé en 2024 de 300 équivalents
temps plein et d'ici 2027 c'est 1
milliard d'euros supplémentaires par an
qui sera consacré à l'accompagnement à
l'insertion et au retour à l'emploi dans
le même temps une enveloppe de 170
millions d'euros est aussi prévue pour
les département pour accompagner la mise
en œuvre de la réforme et pour densifier
l'offre de solution d'accompagnement
socio-pressionnel ainsi que lever les
freins périphériques ces moyens
permettront donc la montée en charge
progressive de la réforme avant même la
date d'entrée de de pleine entrée en
vigueur au 1er janvier
2025 au-delà de ces moyens à louer et
au-delà des mesures initiales je
souhaite aussi souligner que le débat
parlementaire a précisé et compléteré ce
projet de loi sur le plein emploi et je
me réjouis donc de l'adoption d'un texte
enrichi c'est la raison pour laquelle je
tiens à nouveau vous remercier pour les
travaux de qualité qui ont été menés ici
comme au Sénat parmi les apports majeurs
je pense notamment à la meilleure prise
en compte des situations individuelles
concernant le contenu du contrat
d'engagement il s'agit par exemple de
fixer l'intensité de l'accompagnement et
grâce à vos débats
la rédaction retenue assure cette prise
en compte des difficultés particulières
rencontré par chacun je pense notamment
à la définition des situations
particulières concernant les aidants les
personnes en situation dehicap les
familles monoparentales avec les les
amendements de Monsieur virir et de
Monsieur Juvin cette attention portée
aux situations particulières va dans le
bon sens celui de la personnalisation de
notre approche d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi elle se retrouve également dans
notre volonté de préciser quelles sont
les jeunes accompagnés dans les missions
locales concerné par l'inscription à
France travail pour que cela concerne
bien évidemment les jeunes en contrat
d'engagement jeune et en passéa de même
l'assemblée dans ses travaux s'est
efforcé de trouver un juste équilibre
dans le contrôle de la récherche
effective d'emploi par les demandeurs
d'emploi le système retenu sera à la
fois plus efficace plus progressif plus
juste que le système actuel et je pense
notamment l'amendement de Michel Peron
enfin s'agissant de la gouvernance vos
débats ont approfondi la réflexion sur
au moins deux aspects d'abord en prenant
soin de conforter la place des
partenaires sociaux dans la gouvernance
et ensuite avec le texte issu de vos
travaux vous confirmez la place des
missions locales dans la réforme de
France travail et je tiens aussi à
saluer le travail qu'elle réalise tous
les jours sur le terrain auprès des plus
jeunes en rappelant une fois de plus que
ni leur gouvernance ni leur statut ni
leur modalité de financement ne sont
modifié l'ensemble de ces apports on
nourri ce projet de loi que les députés
et les sénateurs de la commission mixte
paritaire vous propose d'adopter
aujourd'hui et au nom du gouvernement je
me réjouis de ce compromis équilibré qui
affirme et raffermit l'ambition
l'ambition de ce texte il vient après
nos précédentes réformes il est fidèle à
leur esprit conforme à l'objectif dit de
notre action parvenir au plein emploi
vous l'aurez compris le gouvernement est
évidemment très favorable à l'adoption
des conclusions de la
CMP merci Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde
Panau et des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale une motion de
rejet préalable déposée en application
de l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est à Monsieur Louis
Boyard
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Olivier du sopt j'ai appris
quelque chose d'incroyable ce weekend
j'ai appris qu'en fait depuis le début
vous étiez le ministre du Travail euh
voilà parce que moi je suis là depuis le
début en fait j'apprends comme vous et
depuis le début je vous ai seulement vu
faire la réforme des retraites 15
milliards d'euros d'économie la réforme
de l'assurance chômage 2,5 milliards
d'euros d'économie là vous nous proposez
la loi France travail qui va massivement
radier les gens qui sont au RSA alors on
ne sait pas combien est-ce que
d'économie vous allez réaliser mais
monsieur duopt continuez de croire en
vos rêves et vous atteindrez les 20
milliards d'euros d'économie qui
rendront Emmanuel Macron très fier de
vous mais alors voilà j'ai été très
surpris d'apprendre que vous n'étiez pas
le ministre chargé de réaliser des
économies sur le dos des gens qui
galèrent mais le ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion trois
mots pour lesquels on préférerait ne pas
avoir un banquier d'affaires à la tête
de l' sée alors je sais que ça vous
choque quand on dit banquier d'affair à
la tête de l'Élysée mais moi Macron je
lui reproche pas d'être banquier je lui
reproche de mener une politique de
banquier pour la France une start-up
nation dans laquelle vous avez 5
millions de personnes qui sont au
chômage les restos du cœur en faillite 9
millions de personnes qui ne mangent pas
à leur fin et 300000 personnes dans la
rue je lui reproche de diriger la France
comme une banque qui non seulement
rémunère mal ses salariés mais même pire
leur volle de l'argent mes chers
collègues depuis la crise de 2008
c'est-à-dire en 15 ans les salaires ont
augmenté de 13 % les prix eux ont
augmenté de 23 % cela veut dire que
depuis 15 ans chaque année pour les
Français leur salaire par rapport au
prix baisse et l'inflation d'aujourd'hui
montre que vous n'êtes pas capable
d'endiguer la situation alors on peut
réfléchir où s'en va l'argent des
Français si vous demandez au 88 neuron
du rassemblement national et à leur 89e
géralde daranin ils vous répondront que
tout est de la faute des étrangers mais
si jamais vous avez un peu de rigueur et
vous suivez les chiffres vous observez
que depuis depuis 15 ans les revenus des
milliardaires n'ont pas augmenté de 13 %
ils n'ont pas augmenté de 23 % ils ont
augmenté de 270 % 270 %. depuis 15 ans
les salaires des Français baissent les
revenus des milliardaires augmentent
cherchent l'erreur depuis 15 ans la part
de la rémunération du travail a baissé
de 5 % la part de la rémunération du
capital a augmenté de 5 % cherchz
l'erreur l'abbé Pierre disait la
politique c'est choisir à qui on va
prendre le fric et à qui on va le donner
et bien notre banquier d'affaires de
président de la République a choisi de
prendre l'argent dans la poche des
Français pour la mettre dans la poche
des milliardaires mais et si ce n'était
que ça monsieur le ministre du Travail
et si ce n'était que le salaire le
problème mais malheureusement la startup
nation elle empire aussi les conditions
de travail et pour vous donner un
exemple je vais vous parler de la
sous-traitance pour ceux qui ne savent
pas ce qui'est la sous-traitance c'est
un peu comme le gouvernement avec
mckinse une entreprise vient vous voir
et elle vous dit bah je peux faire le
travail en moins cher donc en moins bien
et surtout en exploitant les salariés
quo que avec minse quand vous leur avez
donné 1 million d'euros pour les
PowerPoint c'était une politique
salariale très généreuse mais
laissez-moi vous parler de mon meilleur
ami Lilian qui lui travaille dans la
sous-traitance à l'aéroport d'Orly et
bien Lilian il travaille de nuit pour
seulement 4 % d'augmentation 4 %
d'augmentation est-ce que vous le feriez
vous désorganiseer votre vie travailleer
de nuit pour seulement 4 %
d'augmentation
c'est une question que j'aurais pu poser
au ministre du Travail malheureusement
il est trop occupé premièrement à ne pas
écouter deuxièmement à à réaliser des
économie et surtout troisièmement à
lui-même faire de la sous-traitance
parce que Monsieur dusopt et j'aimerieis
que vous écoutez à l'aéroport d'Orly le
PDG d'Air France a annoncé qu'il allait
délocaliser les emplois à l'aéroport
Roisy Charles de Gaulle 1000 salariés
sont concernés alors il peut il dit
toujours au salariés ne vous inquiétez
pas vous pourrez rester sur l'aéroport
mais vous devrez travailler à Transavia
Transavia filiel lowcost qui fait dans
la sous-traitance monsieur le ministre
comment pouvez-vous dire à ces salariés
de maintenant aller travailler dans la
sous-traitance l'État est actionnaire
majoritaire de Air France comment vous
pouvez laisser cela se dérouler sous vos
yeux et me répondre que le PDG d'Air
France est un très bon ami d'Emmanuel
Macron est certes vrai mais ce n'est pas
non plus une bonne réponse
3,5 millions de salariés sont dans la
sous-traitance c'est 20 % de plus qui il
a 15 ans vous ne faites qu'empirer la
situation alors arrivé à ce stade je me
suis posé une question que beaucoup de
Français se posent tous les jours y y
a-t-il un domaine dans lequel ce
gouvernement est compétent un sujet dans
lequel vous arrivez à être fort alors
j'ai longtemps réfléchi j'ai longtemps
cherché et j'ai trouvé un sujet sur
lequel vous êtes très fort c'est diviser
les Français les monter les uns contre
les autres sur tous les sujets le
travailleur contre le chômeur le
français contre l'immigré le jeune
contre le retraité les guerres de
religion vous adorez ça les guerres de
religion parce que ça vous permet une
chose ça vous permet d'éviter qu'on
aborde dans cette Assemblée nationale ce
qui devrait être l'un de nos sujets
principaux dans la mesure où c'est l'une
des principales préoccupations des
Français c'est la question de la lutte
des classes ne sousestimez pas cela 83 %
des Français estiment que la lutte des
classes est une réalité dans notre pays
aujourd'hui et ils ont raison ils ont
raison quand ils voient les
délocalisations ils ont raison quand ils
voient les baisses de salairees ils ont
raison quand ils voient leurs conditions
de travail et ils ont raison quand ils
vous désignent comme principal
responsable du chômage structurel que
nous vivons dans notre pays ne croyez
pas que les Français sont d'accord avec
ce que vous racontez sur les chômeurs et
les gens RA tout le monde comprend que
vous cherchez à monter les Français les
uns contre les autres tout le monde sait
qu'un RSA de confort ça n'existe pas
vivre avec 600 € en période d'inflation
ce n'est pas du confort tout le monde
sait que le chômage de confort ça
n'existe pas d'ailleurs les 3/4 des
chômeurs ne sont même pas indemnisés et
vous devriez vous poser la question
pourquoi est-ce que des chômeurs qui ne
sont même pas indemnisés refuse des
emplois mais la réponse elle est très
simple c'est parce qu'on aimerait bien
vous y voir vous on aimerait bien vous y
voir vous monsieur le ministre du
Travail travailler dans la restauration
métier en tenstion à rester debout 15h
par jour avec des clients qui vous
parlent mal despuses ou vous galérez
dans le transport dans la bagnole pour
1383 € par mois on aimerait bien vous y
voir vous et en attendant de vous y voir
en attendant de vous voir vous
intéresser à ces Français sachez que
dire qu'il suffit de traverser la rue
pour trouver du boulot est une phrase
inacceptable qu'un président de la
République ne devrait jamais prononcer
certainement pas dans un pays où il y a
seulement 350000 emplois disponibles
pour 5 millions de personnes privées
d'emploi ce sont les chiffres de votre
ministère monsieur le ministre le
problème du chômage c'est la question de
la pénurie
d'emploi racontez aux Français que ce
sont les gens au chômage au RSA qui nous
coûteent cher c'est un mensonge une
escroquerie et vous le savez très bien
parce que vous vous gardez bien de dire
qu'à l'origine dans le processus les
très grandes entreprise devaient
contribuer et que aujourd'hui vous leur
faites 90 milliards de cadeaux fiscaux
par an mais dites-nous monsieur le
ministre dites-nous pourquoi est-ce que
vous faites 90 milliards de cadeaux fisc
parents à ces très grandes entreprises
parce qu'elles sont censé créer des
emplois et elles ne le font pas vous ne
vous faites pas respecter et qui a eu
cette idée de génie qui a eu l'idée de
génie de faire des cadeaux fiscaux pour
créer des emplois sans qu'il ne soit
jamais créé c'est Emmanuel Macron quand
il était ministre de l'économie de
François Hollande il a dit je vais
donner 100 milliards d'euros aux très
grandes entreprises pour qu'ell crée un
million d'emplois avec le cice résultat
elles ont créé 100000 emplois elles ont
pris l'argent et elles l'ont mis dans
leur poche Emmanuel Macron s'est fait
humilier et vous osez appeler ça un
Mozart de la finance
et c'est parce que vous êtes ridicule
que vous faites ce projet de loi France
travail parce que vous devez continuer
de faire des économies pour gaver ces
gens-là vous dites que vous allez
inscrire automatiquement à Pôle Emploi
les gens qui sont au RSA pour mieux les
accompagner mais vous ne créez que 300
postes de conseiller pô emploi
supplémentaire alors qu'ils ont déjà la
tête sous l'eau vous êtes ridicule vous
dites que vous voulez faire travailler
15 he par semaine les gens qui sont au
RSA on parle de 2 millions de personnes
c'est totalement irréalisable et vous le
savez très bien parce que tout ce que
vous cherchez à faire c'est radier le
plus d'allocataire possible pour essayer
de faire des économies parce que en ce
moment vous cherchez à faire des
économies partout et quand on voit ce
que vous avez fait de l'hôpital public
on voit jusqu'où vous êtes prêt à aller
pour faire des économies alors mes chers
collègues je terminerai en vous posant
une question simple très simple ces gens
qui sont au RSA une fois que vous les
aurez radiés une fois que vous les aurez
privé de revenus ils vont devenir quoi
ils vont devenir quoi si ce n'est des
noms supplémentaires qui s'ajouteront à
la longue liste des 300000 personnes qui
dorment à la rue aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues pensez-y
pensez-y dans cette Assemblée nationale
nous votons pour 70 millions de
personnes nos actes ont des conséquences
nos votes ont des conséquences devant
vous vous avez les boutons qui vous
permettent de voter pour ou contre cette
loi ici vous avez le cœur qui est censé
vous aider à réfléchir si vous votez
cette loi des gens dormiront à la rue
alors mes chers collègues si par malheur
vous étiez amené à voter cette loi si
par inconscience vous étiez amené à
voter cette loi les Français se
souviendront de ces mots de l'abé pierre
qui disait que les hommes politiques
comme vous ne connaissent la misère du
peuple que par les statistiques et que
malheureusement pour le peuple vous ne
pleurez jamais devant les chiffres ne
votez pas cette loi
merci
monsieur le
député je vous informe que sur le vote
de la motion de rejet préalable je suis
saisie par le groupe la France insoumise
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale d'une demande de scrutin public
le scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale nous en venons
aux explication de vote madame Stéphanie
Rist
merci Madame la la présidente et voilà
voilà une énième motion de rejet de la
France insoumise alors même qu'un
compromis a été trouvé entre les deux
chambres vous êtes dans l'opposition
systématique nous voulons contrairement
à vous offrir un avenir professionnel à
tous oui restaurer la dignité de tous
les demandeurs d'emploi pour une société
inclusive cela ne pourra se faire sans
la caboration avec tous les acteurs
locaux d'ailleurs vendredi nous avons pu
assister à la signature d'un protocole
expérimental de notre président de
région avec le ministre pour la première
brique concrète de ces lois un protocole
expérimental régional France travail ce
texte permet la transformation du
service public de l'emploi c'est un pas
de plus dans notre objectif du plein
emploi d'abord et surtout pour les gens
eux-même le travail permettant une
réelle émancipation avec notre politique
nous avons baissé le ch nous avons créé
2 millions d'emplois toujours pour les
gens eux-mêmes nous devons poursuivre
c'est ce que fait ce texte et vous
l'aurez compris nous ne voterons pas
votre motion de
rejet merci madame la députée la parole
est à madame la Présidente Mathilde
Panau merci madame la
Présidente le président des riches est
l'ennemi des pauvres et comme le disait
Bert BR si les puissants de la terre
sont capable de provoquer la misère ils
sont incapables d'en supporter la vue
oui vous êtes incapable de supporter la
vue de votre bilan le nombre de
personnes sans abri a doublé en disant
dans notre pays 2822 enfants dorment à
la rue 700 son â de moins de 3 ans soit
une augmentation de 42 % en 1 mois vous
êtes incapable de supporter la vue de la
fin qui disloque le pays au point que un
français sur 6 se prive régulièrement
d'un repas vous êtes incapable de
regarder en face la pauvreté qui
s'accrave comme le montre le Secours
Catholique avec les femmes et les
enfants qui en sont les premières
victime alors qu'avez-vous fait depuis 6
ans plutôt que de mener une politique
pour supprimer la pauvreté et la misère
vous avez décidé de supprimer
l'Observatoire de la pauvreté et donc de
faire disparaître les pauvres ça ne vous
a pas suffi avec deux réformes de
l'assurance chômage décrié par tous les
syndicats vous avez là aussi refusé de
combattre le chômage préférant faire
faire la chasse aux chômeurs et vous
avez là aussi fait disparaître les
chômeurs puisque les radiations on
augmenté de 10 % au Pôle emploi
c'est-à-dire plus de chômeurs
disparition des chiffres et puis ensuite
pour écouter vos félicitations moins
d'un chômeur sur de indemnisé vous avez
baissé l'indemnisation en mentant et
enent temp des chômeurs alors que 14000
personnes meurent chaque année du fait
du chômage de longue durée mais là aussi
ça ne vous a pas suffi aujourd'hui ce
que vous proposez il n'est pas trop tard
pour l'arrêter vous proposer que les
personnes en situation de handicap les
allocataires du RSA les privés d'emploi
se retrouvent tous inscrits à France
travail avec les pai de dagmocles de se
retrouver radié personne ne trouve grâce
à vos yeux même lorsque nous avons
demandé à ce que les maires célibataires
avec leurs enfants ne puissent pas être
privé de leur RSA c'est-à-dire 500 à 600
€ par mois vous l'avez refusé alors nous
avons bien compris c'est quoi qu'il en
coûte pour les multinationales et le C40
est pas d'agent magique pour les pauvres
és
deeette de pouretrouver votre
digité la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
vir
merci merci madame la Présidente le
groupe les républicain votera contre
cette motion de rejet pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est qu'on
est quand même mes chers collègues au
terme d'un processus législatif d'un
parcours législatif au cours duquel on a
pu amender bonifier modifier jet de loi
tel que on le considère nécessaire pour
le pays oui nous sommes pour le plein
emploi oui nous considérons que l'emploi
est vertueux oui on considère que l'on
s'insère dans la société par le travail
et trouver les passerelles à chacun pour
permettre à des hommes et à des femmes
qui jusquà présent sont exclus sont
écartés de retrouver une dignité de
retrouver un avenir parce qu'on va
s'occuper d'eux ça nous paraît
incontournable nous sommes plutôt fiers
effectivement d'avoir contribué à ce
qu'il y ait des désormais d'une part 100
% des bénéficiaires du RSA qui soi
accompagné qui soi considérés ce n'était
pas le cas jusqu'à présent il y avait un
système qui admettait factuellement que
des bénéficiaires du RSA soient laissés
pour compte désormais avec ce projet de
loi tous les bénéficiaires du RSA
bénéficieront d'un accompagnement
personnalisé individualisé qui doit les
remettre dans un chemin pour retrouver
leur place dans la société qui peut être
contre ce principe sauf à admettre
effectivement qu'on se complet à
admettre que certains soient exclus nous
nous sommes pour l'inclusion nous nous
sommes pour que chacun trouve sa place
dans la société et on considère
effectivement que de demander une
contrepartie maximum de 15 he adapté au
profil par profil c'est une chance pour
toutes les personnes de cette société
française c'est une des raisons pour
lesquell nous avons mis toute notre
force pour que ce projet de loi soit
amendé soit bonifié dans cette
directionl et je le rappelle très
simplement mes chers collègues on on a
l'article 5 du Préambule de la
Constitution qui une chose très fort
chacun a le droit à l'emploi chacun a le
devoir de travailler c'est comme ça
qu'on fait nation c'est comme ça qu'on
fera une cohésion nationale en redonnant
à chacun une place de la société par le
travail merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Anne
bergand merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre chers collègues chers
collègues de de la France insoumise vous
accourdez un mérite c'est celui de la
constance à chaque texte sa motion
doncun pourrait s'en lcer mais je vois
ça plutôt je vois ça plutôt comme une
opportunité une opportunité de rappeler
que ce PJL est un texte de progrès
équilibré porté par l'ambition
d'apporter une meilleure coordination
des acteurs au plus près des territoires
et avec la volonté de miser sur
l'accompagnement des demandur d'emploi
et des entreprises on peut d'ailleurs
également se féliciter du compromis en
CMP ont été trouvé sans dénaturer
l'objet du texte comme cela a été
rapporté rappelé par le rapporteur se
féliciter également de la réintégration
de l'article 10 du service public de la
petite enfance dans la version
définitive on ne pouvait pas décemment
souligner les difficultés rencontré par
les familles monoparentales souvent des
femmes à accéder à l'emploi et ne pas se
donner les moyens de les aider sur le
volet relatif à la garde des enfants
cette motion est également une
opportunité de pointer l'attitude de
certains collègues notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux ils se reconnaîtront qui
se livre à de véritables campagnes de
désinformation sur ce texte je reprends
les exemples des familles monoparentales
comment peut-on s'émouvoir que ce texte
pénalise supposément les M isolées et
voter la suppression de son article sur
la petite enfance comment peut-on
affirmer que ce Dex représente un danger
pour les victimes de violence conjugale
oui vous avez bien entendu c'est ce
qu'on peut lire sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est absolument scandaleux et faux
comment peut-on mentir au point affirmer
que ce texte prône le travail gratuit
sous peine de suspension immédiate du
RSA chers collègues vous savez que c'est
faux vous savez très bien que l'article
2 prévoit la possibilité de moduler la
duréedomadaire de 15 he en fonction des
situations individuelles des personnes
situation de monopentalité d'handicap
d'incapacité je pense que tous les
citoyens méritent mieux que des
mensonges surtout quand le texte apporte
les moyens concrets d'un accompagnement
renforcé et efficace notre groupe bien s
contre cette motion merci madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur Arthur
de la porte merci merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais juste poser une
question est-ce que à défaut d'avoir
ouvert ses oreilles le ministre a au
moins ouvert un dictionnaire par que moi
je l'ai fait dans Larousse travail
activité professionnelle régulière et
rémunéré vivre de son
travail ici vous parlez de France
travail mais justement nous on parle des
gens qui ne travaillent pas qui ne
peuvent pas travailler qui n'arrivent
pas à travailler c'est les allocataires
du RSA qu'est-ce que vous leur promettez
aux allocataires du RSA de vivre moins
bien sans pour autant pouvoir travailler
alors oui vous avez créé le réseau
France travail pour mettre tout le monde
au travail dites-vous mais le ministre
l'a lui-même reconnu tout le monde ne
peut pas travailler vous allez imposer
une obligation d'inscription à Pôle
emploi pour tous les allocataires du ça
c'est une folie et vous le savez c'est
pour cela que nous vous demandons de
renvoyer ce texte en commission c'est
non seulement une folie mais elle se
traduit par un vocabulaire
technocratique dont vous seul avez le
savoir qui fait que vous avez voulu
créer donc France travail après avoir
créé France relance après avoir créé
France Raay le réseau des acteurs de
l'insertion et de l'emploi vous le
nommez désormais France rade parce que
finalement oui c'est le réseau des
acteurs de l'emploi vous avez supprimé
l'insertion qui était pourtant la seule
chose que le RMI promettait à celles et
ceux qui avaient peu le revenu minimum
d'insertion maintenant c'est France rad
et bien chers collègues je ne suis pas
fier aujourd'hui d'être avec vous pour
voter ce texte ce texte qui va faire une
chose alors même que aujourd'hui le
Secours Catholique rend son rapport
annuel sur la pauvreté qu'il dit son
inquiétude sur les effets de votre
réforme de l'assurance chômage qu'il dit
son inquiétude sur les effets de cette
réforme sur l'augmentation de la
précarité que va produire ce texte c'est
pas du
c'est de la rade c'est des gens qui sont
en galère c'est des gens qui n'en
pourront plus et qui pourront encore
moins bien faire avec peu c'està-dire
vivre mal mais encore moins bien à cause
de vos réformes j'espère que vous en
avez confiance c'est pourquoi évidemment
nous voterons cette motion de Reet merci
monsieur le député mes chers collègues
si vous voulez discuter entre vous je
vous invite à le faire un tout petit peu
moins
fort sortir ou de sortir comme vous le
souhaitez il reste orateurs avant le
vote donc vous pouvez effectivement
sortir pour discuter dehors et pour les
collègues je rappelle qui pensent
qu'avec des oreillettes sans fil on ne
les voit pas téléphoner dans l'hémicycle
erreur on les voit la parole est à
Monsieur François
gerernigon merci merci madame la
Présidente le groupe horizon soutient
l'emploi l'insertion et le retour à
l'emploi pour ceux qui on sont éloignés
depuis longtemps ceci afin de retrouver
une dignité avec la volonté de tirer
vers le haut les personnes tomb dans
l'ornière le groupe horizon votera donc
contre cette motion de
rejet merci monsieur le
député monsieur alors Monsieur le Député
Gernigon a pu parler dans le calme on
espère que les autres orateurs pourront
en faire autant la parole est à Madame
mariechlotte
Garin merci madame la
Présidente effectivement c'est un peu
agité merci madame la Présidente texte
il était déjà pas reluisant quand on a
pu l'étudier à l'Assemblée nationale ça
a effectivement empiré au Sénat
finalement sans surprise parce que c'est
la prolongation de la casse sociale que
vous menez que ça soit avec le texte sur
l'assurance chômage ou bien la réforme
des retraites ici avec ce texte vous
stigmatisez les plus vulnérables sans
donner plus de moyens aux personnes qui
l'accompagnent il y a rien sur le non
recours il y a des mesurettes sur
l'autonomie le handicap la petite
enfance c'est une vision du travail qui
n'est pas la nôtre parce que le plein
emploi à tout prix et à n'importe quel
prix ça sera pas avec nous pas pour nous
nous voterons donc pour cette motion de
rejet merci madame la députée la parole
est à Monsieur Pierre
daréville merci madame la Présidente ce
ce projet de loi est un texte de de
stigmatisation et d'infantilisation de
celles et ceux qui sont privés d'emploi
avec cette norme qui est affiché de 15h
d'activité au moins activité dont on ne
sait rien ou pas grand-chose ce texte
c'est la négation du décalage entre le
nombre d'offres d'emploi et la demande
d'emploi dans notre pays qui est
considérable c'est une logique de
forçage et ce n'est pas respecter le
travail ce n'est pas respecter celles et
ceux qui travaillent au bout du compte
d'ailleurs avec la grande confusion que
vous organisez entre ce qui relève de la
protection sociale et ce qui relève de
la solidarité nationale et bien c'est
une attaque contre les droits acquis par
par le travail nous allons donc nous
opposer à ce texte qui vient modifier le
rôle de pôul emploi qui deviendra France
travail et dans un certain nombre de cas
France radiation et nous pensons
évidemment qu'il faut prendre les choses
d'une tout autre façon avec l'accord que
vous avez passé avec les les
républicains au Sénat vous êtes sur ce
texte je le crains hélas comme sur
d'autres sur un terrain très glissant
avec les décisions que nous sommes en
train de prendre pour beaucoup de femmes
et d'hommes ça sera plus de misère et
plus de galère nous allons voter cette
motion merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin
saintthuile merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
quand nous avons entrevu l'idée
d'évoquer le plein emploi nous avons
pensé travailleurs nous avons pensé
salaire nous avons pensé au reprise
d'activités mais finalement sur ces
sujets vous n'avez rien à
proposer pire vous faites le choix de ne
pas répondre à l'inquiétude légitime de
ceux qui travaillant ne vivent pas
dignement de leur travail vous faites le
choix de considérer que la seule réponse
à apporter à ceux qui ne vivrai pas de
leur travail ce serait d'abaisser encore
un peu plus les conditions de vie et de
revenus d'assistance de ceux qui n'ont
pas d'activité vous faites le choix
mensonger de mettre en place un texte
inapplicable que tous les professionnels
relèvent comme inapplicable vous ne
tirez aucun enseignement des limites du
contrat d'engagement jeune vous ne tirez
aucun enseignement des expérimentations
qui ne sont pas arrivées à terme lors de
la première lecture le groupe lot
s'était refusé à participer au vote
d'une motion de rejet considérant que
c'était par le travail la discussion et
la capacité des parlementaires à amender
le texte que nous trouverions une voix
de passage force de constater que ça n'a
pas été possible dans la grande majorité
le groupe lot votera donc cette motion
de Reger
préalable merci monsieur le
député nous allons maintenant procéder
au scrutin je vais donc mettre au voix
la motion de rejet
préalable je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
264 exprimé 236 majorité 119 pour 73
contre 163 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté la parole est à Madame Michelle
perron pour le groupe
Renaissance merci beaucoup c'est
gentil
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le ministre madamees
et monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous arrivons à la dernière
étape de notre parcours législatif pour
cette loi cadre nous pouvons affirmer
avec fierté que ce projet de loi a été
enrichi par nos échange ici et au sein
du Sénat en effet ce projet de loi porte
cette ambition
un emploi pour tous un accompagnement
socio-professionnel renforcé pour les
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin une
transformation du service public de
l'emploi et de
l'insertion ce projet de loi permet de
poser le cadre afin de permettre une
amélioration substantielle de l'offre de
service proposé aux personnes en
recherche d'emploi mais également aux
entreprises grâce à une meilleure
coopération des
acteurs un des points de désaccord
principaux avec le Sénat résidait dans
la dénomination de Pôle emploi et du
réseau si nous avions rétabli la
dénomination du texte initial à savoir
opérateur France travail et réseau
France travail nous avons trouvé un
point d'équilibre avec nos collègues
sénateurs sur l'appellation suivante
Paul emploi sera bel et bien l'opérateur
France travail et le réseau sera
intitulé le réseau pour
l'emploi loin de constituer un Simp
marqueur symbolique celui-ci
accompagnera la réforme en profondeur du
service public de l'emploi porté par ce
projet de loi à l'attention de ses
usagers et de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens la marque France travail
permettra à chacun d'identifier la
nouvelle approche du réseau dans
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et d'acter le positionnement de son
principal opérateur chargé de la
production d'un patrimoine commun à la
disposition de tous
la transformation de Pôle emploi en
France travail permettra également de
mobiliser les équipes de l'opérateur
autour d'un nouveau projet en lien avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'emploi et de
l'insertion dans un souci de consensus
et de clarté il est proposé que la
marque France travail soit réservée à
l'opérateur du service public de
l'emploi et que la gouvernance soit
assuré par le réseau des acteurs de
l'insertion et de l'emploi ce texte
renforce l'accompagnement des demandeurs
d'emploi et des bénéficiaires du RSA
dans le cadre d'un unique contrat
d'engagement sur le modèle du contrat
engagement jeune qui a déjà fait ses
preuves et d'une inscription automatique
comme demandeur d'emploi pour tous
notamment pour les jeunes suivis par les
missions locales ce renforcement et
cette amélioration des services aux
usagers s'accompagne d'une contrepartie
pour laquelle le bénéficiaire devra
s'engager à suivre un parcours
d'insertion sinon son allocation pourra
être suspendue ou supprimée notamment
sous la forme de 15 he d'activité nous
avons également proposé une nouvelle
rédaction relative aux 15 he d'activité
en effet nous en avons précisé
l'écriture
elle prévoit que le niveau d'intensité
de l'accompagnement dépend de la
situation du demandeur
d'emploi la durée hebdomadaire
d'activité est par principe d'au moins
15 he toutefois cette durée peut-être M
minoré sans pouvoir être nul pour des
raisons liées à la situation
individuelle de l'intéressé et au vue du
diagnostic global les personnes
rencontrant des difficultés
particulières et avérées en raison de
leur état de santé de leur handicap de
leur invalidité ou de leur situation de
parents isolés pourront à leur demande
bénéficier d'un plan d'action sans durée
hebdomadaire
d'activité les dernières modifications
principales portaient sur le service
public de la petite enfance l'arle le 10
a été rétabli au sein de la commission
mixte paritaire suite à sa suppression
en séance à l'Assemblée nationale la
rédaction de l'article 10 est celle d'un
compromis en effet l'entrée en vigueur
des obligations incombants à la commune
en tant qu'autorité organisatrice du
secteur de la petite enfance est fixé au
1er janvier
2025 sauf pour la création des relais
petite enfance dans les communes de plus
de 10000 habitants qui est prévu le 1er
janvier 2026
ainsi la majorité votera pour ce texte
de compromis enrichi par les
parlementaires le plein emploi est à
notre portée messieurs
dame merci madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur Jocelin
de sign pour le groupe rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame monsieur rapporteur
chers collègues laapogé est derrière
vous monsieur le ministre si vous pouvez
encore vous enorgueillir d'une baisse
relative même très relative du nombre de
chômeurs cela ne va pas durer et vous le
savez alors profitez-en tant que vous le
pouvez encore en effet les bons chiffres
de PO emploi se tarissent et ceux de
l'INC inquiète 25 % d'emploi créé fin
juin par rapport aux prévisions et une
remontée du taux de chômage de 7,3
contre 7,1
prévu nous comprenons aujourd'hui un peu
mieux pourquoi il était si urgent de
voter ce texte avant la fin des
résultats de l'expérimentation mise en
place dans 18 départements non votre
projet de loi ne fera pas baisser le
chômage monsieur le ministre non votre
projet de loi n'accompagnera pas mieux
les personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi et non votre projet de loi
n'améliorera pas les conditions de
travail des agents de Pôle emploi ni des
autres structures
territoriales cependant nous devons vous
reconnaître que vous avez le sens de la
chronologie après la réforme du chômage
pendant laquelle vous avez stigmatisé
les demandeurs d'emploi en les faisant
passer pour des faitéants la réforme des
retraites lors de laquelle vous avez
reculé l'âge de départ à 64 ans
aujourd'hui avec ce projet de loi vous
jetez les allocataires du RSA sans
distinction dans une marche en avant
forcée vers l'emploi sans prendre en
compte qu'une partie d'entre eux est
dans une situation incompatible avec une
recherche d'emploi tel que les étudiants
les personnes handicapées en incapacité
de travail et les personnes au foyer de
plus vous leur imposez une
conditionnalité de 15 heur d'activité
par semaine sous peine de suppression de
leur
indemnité monsieur le ministre j'ai une
question pour vous quelle activé
allez-vous demander un bénéficiaire du
RSA dans les zones rurales que vous avez
désindustrialisé que se passera-t-il si
vous n'avez rien à leur proposer
allez-vous malgré tout leur retirer leur
indemnité de
survie malheureusement ma question
restera sans réponse et vous me direz
que la critique est facile alors
qu'avons-nous à proposer et quels sont
nos
solutions dans la France de Marine Le
Pen les allocataires du RSA
bénéficieront d'un accompagnement digne
de ce nom nous leur rendrons leur fierté
en les réintégrant dans le monde du
travail et ne seront plus considérés
comme des parasites dans la France de
Marine Le Pen les employeurs
bénéficieront d'avantage fiscau pour
augmenter les salaires de tous les
employés et pas uniquement ceux qui sont
osmiques dans la France de Marine Le Pen
les seigneurs les seigors seront
valorisés et il participeront à
transmission du savoir-faire auprès des
jeunes
générations enfin dans la France de
Marine Le Pen nous réduirons la distance
entre l'offre et les demandeurs d'emploi
les formations proposées seront mieux
encadrées et en corrélation avec les
besoins du
territoire voilà Monsieur le Ministre ce
que nous avons essayé de vous expliquer
de vous proposer durant ce projet de loi
mais vous êtes resté
sour au bon sens et au pragmatisme
préférant une vision technocratique et
hors sol alors bien sûr c'est sans
surprise que nous ne voterons pas votre
projet de loi votre vision est erronnée
aveuglée que vous êtes par votre
suffisance et votre mépris les
différentes crises que nous avons essuyé
ces dernières années ne vous ont pas
servi de leçon vous n'écoutez ni les
mouvements des gilets jaunes ni les
grèves ni les
manifestations la seule qui trouve grâce
à vos yeux et devant qui vous vous
agenouillez sans froncer un sourcil
c'est l'Union européenne de Madame Van
derleyen vivement le 9
juin je voudrais malgré tout apporter un
message d'espoir à nous compatriotes qui
se sentent opprimés et délaissés par
votre gouvernement une autre vision de
la France existe avec Marine Le Pen vous
serez entendu et vous serez reconnu je
vous
remerci
merci monsieur le
député je vous rappelle que le rôle de
la Président c'est une impartialité
totale mais si vos blagues sont très
drôles ça peut me faire rire et vous ne
m'aidez pas donc je vous remercie de
faire vos blagues plus
doucement la parole est à monsieur
Adrien Clouet pour le groupe la France
insoumise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nup présidente collègu ministres
qui gouverne ce
pays question cruciale alors que vous
présentez un texte qui n'a rien à voir
avec ce qui a été examiné à l'Assemblée
nationale vous vous êtes réunis en petit
comité avec les sénateurs de droite pour
passer au-dessus de nos tête y compris
celle de vos propres rangs macronistes
comme quoi la seule chose que vous voci
autant que les pauvres c'est la
démocratie rappel pour nos concitoyennes
et nos concitoyens qui regardent cette
loi France travaille obligera chômeur et
à locataire du RSA à exercer au moins 15
heur d'activité obligatoire par semaine
ce qui comprend des stages des mission
d'insertion du recrutement par
simulation bref ce qu'on appelle
communément du travail mais non payé
donc s'il est adopté tous les
travailleurs du pays sont susceptibles
d'être concurrencés sur leurs postees
par des gens qu' l'exerceront
gratuitement et ce que je vais vous dire
c'est la réalité que connaît tout le
monde dans ce pays il n'y a qu'un seul
type de personne qui coûte trop cher en
france
ce sont les Boloré les Arnaud les hermè
celles et ceux pour lesquels il n'y a
jamais aucune obligation prévue par
votre majorité alors en hémicycle vous
avez fait semblant de donner des gages
par exemple vous avez adopté notre
proposition d'un article nouveau qui
prévoyait àôemploi la mission de
contrôler les offres d'emploi vérifier
leur légalité si elles sont mensongères
si elles correspondent à un vrai poste
et cetera un problème majeur je vous
cite encore ce matin cette offre trouvée
sur le serveur de pôleemploi d'un CDD de
36 mois à Toulouse manifestement illégal
or en commission le rapporteur était
contre l'ajoute de cet article donc
contre le contrôle de la qualité des
offre à Pôle Emploi puis en hémicycle il
était pour le ministre était pour
également vote à l'unanimité en
commission mixte paréire vous changez
encore d'avis et décider que le patronat
pourra en faire à sa tête et recruter
les gens selon les conditions qui lui
plaisent dans l'arbitraire le plus total
et sans aucun respect du Code du travail
dans ce pays bref en somme lorsque vous
n'employez pas le 493 et et bien vous
allez sournoisement à la nuit tombée
liquider les acquis parlementaires dans
des salons cachés c'est la même chose
pour la représentation des usagers en
situation de handicap c'est oui devant
les caméras et c'est non dès lors qu'il
y a un rideau qui vous
cache non seulement vous votez n'importe
quoi mais en plus vous le faites les
yeux bandés pas d'étude d'impact sur le
texte pas de bilan des expérimentations
pourtant premier en septembre pardon si
si Monsieur Dussau vient faire des
bilans sur des estrades devant des ça à
moitié vide sans fournir jamais aucune
donnée visiblement vous confondez le
bilan et le micro trottoir d'ailleurs
vous croyez tellement peu à ce texte
qu'encore hier monsieur le ministre
htien Orléan lancer une expérimentation
d'un texte de loi qu'on vote aujourd'hui
allez comprendre quant à la
justification vous dites qu'il y aurait
une fraude des allocations au RSA d'un
peu moins de 300 millions d'euros par an
pourquoi insister là-dessus on le sait
très bien c'est pour couvrir le
véritable scandale à savoir les 15
milliards d'euros qui ont disparu de
l'agence de garantie des salaires sous
contrôle
pour 1 € que vous mettez en cause du
côté des bénéficiaires du RSA le
patronat en vole 50 votre préoccupation
c'est donc pas d'être volé mais c'est
d'être volé entre
amis pourquoi le vote a-t-il donc lieu
maintenant le vote a lieu aujourd'hui
car ce texte sert de moyen de pression
dans le cadre des négociations de la
nouvelle convention d'assurance chômage
en décidant de radier les allocataire du
RSA dans la webcam aurait un problème le
jour du rendez-vous en décidant de
radier l'agriculteur RSA qui refuserait
15 heur de travail obligatoire par
exemple qui sait en allant la bourrer le
champ du voisin vu que vous avez déjà
coupé les aides àroos environnemental en
témoigne la mobilisation ce midi en
décidant de radier les parents isolés
qui ne peuvent pas donner suite à du
bénévolat à 40 bornes de chez eux et
bien vous avez envoyé un message au
mdeef tout est permis sonnezla la
lie ils l'ont bien compris ils l'ont
bien compris alors que le chômage
remonte ils viennent d'arracher un
cadeau avec votre bénédiction de 400
milliards d'euros de baisse de
cotisation durant ces négociations de
l'assurance chômage cet argent
permettrait d'indemniser 30000 chômeurs
mais vous avez d'autres priorités le
cadeau fiscal passe avant tout et les
pauvres à la fin si Monsieur dau n'est
plus qu'un chargé d'affaires du meddef
où se tourner d'abord vers les collègues
présents même si le nombre est tout à
fait insuffisant ceux et celles qui
n'ont pas une âme de paillasson vteront
contre ce texte au nom de ce qu'ils ont
adopté dans cette Assemblée nationale
avant d'être trahi par leurs
représentantes et leurs représentants
puis puis ah bah peut-être vous mais
j'imagine que ce pas le cas de tout le
monde ensuite en nous nous tournerons
vers le Conseil constitutionnel
puisqu'en prévoyant la suppression
totale du RSA en cas de violation des
engagements des bénéficiaires vous
punissez les enfants pour les erreurs ou
les fautes de leurs parents rétablissant
le principe du châtiment collectif vous
l'avez compris collègu nous voterons
contre ce texte et si comme nous le
comme nous l'espérons vous n'avez pas de
majorité et bien vous n'aurez qu'à
traverser la rue pour en trouver une
merci beaucoup monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Juvin pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nousons donc donc à la fin de
ce débat sur le RSA qui était un débat
extrêmement nécessaire puisque nous
l'avons vu il a été l'occasion de
clarifier un certain nombre de choses ce
que nous devions dire et et voir c'est
d'abord très simple c'est la situation
du pays qui tient malheureusement en
quelques mots une situation dégradée
avec 3000 milliards de dettes tous les
services publics tous les services
publics qui sont financés à crédit et
l'absence de marge de manœuvre puisque
la première dépens de l'État ce sont
désormais malheureusement où ça va être
les intérêts de la dette alors pourquoi
en sommes-nous là nous en sommes là pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que nous
dépensons mal l'argent des Français je
dis bien l'argent des Français pas
l'argent public parce que il n'y a pas
d'argent public il n'y a que de l'argent
des Français qu'on prend dans la poche
des Français cet argent nous le
dépensons pas comme il faudrait que nous
le
dépensions et puis nous en sommes là
aussi parce que nous ne travaillons pas
assez et le débat sur le RSA en fait
c'est un débat sur le travail nous au
républicains nous nous pensons tout
d'abord qu'une partie de notre système
social est dévoyé il est dévoyé parce
qu'une partie du système social
désincite au travail la deuxième chose à
laquelle nous avons considéré qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait mettre en avant
c'était que la valeur du travail en
réalité c'est que le travail c'est le
meilleur moyen de sortir de la pauvreté
et que si le travail n'est pas favorisé
et bien la pauvreté n'est pas prête
d'être combatue et et encore moins
évidemment vaincue avec cette loi sur le
RSA nous avions donc deux objectifs
d'abord que tous ceux qui peuvent
travailler travaillent et un deuxième
objectif que tous ceux qui se retrouve
seul face au chômage puisse être
accompagné sur le premier point quand on
reçoit le RSA on a le devoir de
s'engager dans une démarche d'insertion
vers le travail et la société a le droit
de contrôler que vous respectez cette
obligation parce que et je le redis
l'argent du RSA c'est l'argent de ceux
qui travaillent et qui cotisent
alors oui nous les républicains nous
redisons cette chose très simple les
Français qui travaillent et qui cotisent
ont le droit de demander des comptes sur
ce qu'on fait de leur argent c'est
pourquoi nous sommes très satisfaits de
l'accord qui a été trouvé quand on
reçoit le RSA sauf exception et sauf
pour des raisons qui devront s'analyser
au cas par cas on doit 15 he d'activité
par semaine les parents isolés les
personnes malades ou en situation de
handicap pourront évidemment être
exempté de cette obligation
mais il y a une contrepartie la
contrepartie c'est que aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes au RSA une fois sur de on ne
vous propose rien pour vous réinsérer
nous voulons quand vous êtes au RSA que
vous ayez le droit d'être accompagné
vers l'activité alors ce que vous allez
voter mes chers collègues et fuyz les
caricatures en réalité ce sont deux
choses d'abord une obligation pour le
bénéficiaire 15 he par semaine mais
aussi une obligation pour la société de
former les bénéficiaires c'est ça la
réalité du texte que nous votons et puis
c'est vrai il y a eu le fameux article
10 qui créait en toute modestie un
service public de la petite
enfance comme si les maires avaient
d'ailleurs attendu pour ouvrir des
crèches mais bon bref passons alors dans
l'accord avec le Sénat nous sommes
satisfaits d'avoir recentré les choses
sur la commune et d'avoir supprimé cette
fameuse j'ouvre les guillemets stratégie
nationale et le contrôle du préfet
c'est-à-dire cette idée très française
que les services publics en l'occurrence
les crèches fonctionneraient mieux si le
ministre si Paris s'en mêlait moi je
crois à la décentralisation je crois que
les services publics sont mieux servis
quand on fait confiance aux acteurs de
terrain les maires en l'occurrence les
directeurs de crèche et que surtout
surtout si on veut que ça marche il faut
absolument éviter l'interventionnisme
tatillon de l'administration centrale
qui nous aur répondu des circulaires
dont là le secret et donc dans nos
discussions nous sommes très satisfaits
de l'accord qui a été trouvé avec le
Sénat et qui permet de recentrer sur
l'action communale et de noter aussi que
le rôle du département est limité au
contrôle de la sécurité et de la qualité
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs un mot pour
conclure sur le RSA puisque c'est quand
même l'essentiel du texte tous les
patrons de PME de TPE tous les artisans
coberant vous disent la même chose ils
cherchent du monde ils arrivent pas à
embaucher et pourtant il y a 5 millions
de chômeurs alors il faut que nous les
écoutions et parce que vous avez compris
Mesdames et Messieurs que le pays ne
sortira du gouffre dans lequel il
s'enfonce que s'il travaille plus vous
voterez comme les républicains pour un
RSA qui ramène au travail et pas pour un
RSA versé pour tout compte qui exclut
l'antement de la
société merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Nicolas turquis
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieur le
rapporteur la présidente de commission
chers collègues nous voilà réunie pour
voter définitivement le texte sur le
plein emploi enfin devrais-je dire tous
ici j'en suis certain nous avons
accompagné des personnes en difficulté
soit en tant qu'élu local soit en tant
que parlementaire et tous nous avons
constaté et parfois découvert qu'en
matière d'emploi l'organisation des
acteurs était non seulement complexe
mais parfois source d'incohérence et de
blocage tous aussi nous avons vu que
souvent pour ces mêmes personnes le
véritable frein par rapport à l'emploi
n'était pas la question de la compétence
mais d'un ensemble de facteurs qui
empêche d'aller au travail c'est tout
d'abord la question de la mobilité
comment aller au boulot à 20 km si on n
pas le permis ou pas le véhicule c'est
aussi la question de la garde des
enfants comment imaginer d'aller
sereinement au travail s'il n'y a pas de
solution de garde pour les enfants ou si
cette solution est plus onéreuse que la
rémunération du travail on pourrait
aussi parler des freins liés à la santé
au handicap à la maîtrise de la langue
ou de l'informatique qui parfois se
cumule ce texte propose de répondre à
ces constats à la fois en coordonnant
mieux les acteurs de l'emploi et à la
fois en en inscrivant dans la loi la
nécessité de prendre en compte tout ce
qui freine le retour à l'emploi au-delà
des sujets habituel de formation de
compétences mais voilà tous sans
exception c'est une certitude nous avons
été confrontés à cette difficulté qui
sont presque un lieu commun et pourtant
nous venons d'examiner une motion de
rejet et pourtant les débats ont été apr
en
hémicycle à quel moment allons-nous
essayer de faire œuvre utile pour le
pays et nos concitoyens au lieu de faire
de la politique de base
étage il est compréhensible de seoser
sur des questions budgétaires par
exemple mais pas pour permettre à nos
concitoyens de revenir vers l'emploi
plus facilement qui plus est sur des
constats que nous partageons tous alors
oui au groupe démocratees nous sommes
fiers de voter ce texte qui est un texte
de bon sens lespôle emploi les missions
locales Cap Emploi les écoles de la
deuxième chance les territoires zéro
chômeurs et cetera ont tous leur
spécificités leur utilité mais ils
doivent se coordonner notamment au
niveau local c'est l'esprit de France
travail c'est une bonne chose et c'est
tout simplement du bon sens construire
des solutions avec les collectivités
locales pour permettre à des parents
isolés souvent des femmes d'avoir pour
leurs enfants des possibilités de garde
de proximité et après abordable c'est du
bon sens ce projet de loi ne règlera pas
tous les problèmes d'inertion
professionnelle nous le savons bien pour
autant il nous permet de nous donner les
moyens de ne laisser personne de côté
car contrairement aux oppositions à
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite de
cette hémicycle nous ne baissons pas les
bras face au chômage nous ne baissons
pas les bras face à l'isolement nous ne
baissons pas les bras face à la pauvreté
des solutions peuvent et doivent être
apporté aux personnes en difficulté
d'insertion professionnelle à vous
écoutter l'immobilisme serait la
solution nous ne le croyons pas et c'est
pourquoi nous renforçons de manière
inédite l'accompagnement des demandeurs
d'emploi le groupe démocrate votera pour
ce projet de loi pour toutes ces
personnes que la collectivité doit mieux
accompagner vers l'emploi et vers
l'insertion je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Arthur de
laapte pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues on ne vise pas la dignité
on vise le minimum ça c'est ce que m'a
dit Christine la responsable du Secours
Catholique d'Argence vendredi midi parce
que les bénévoles du Secours Catholique
ils sont aujourd'hui
exang ils n'en peuvent plus et ils
subissent vos réformes monsieur le
ministre je vais vous faire un peu de
lecture c'est un rapport j'espère que
vous aurez l'occasion de de lire c'est
celui sur l'état de la pauvreté qui a
été publié aujourd'hui par Secours
Catholique même si je ne mange pas
l'essentiel ce sont mes enfants voilà ce
que disent aujourd'hui des femmes
précaires pendant que vous regardez
votre téléphone ce rapport nous il nous
touche il nous heurte je vais vous en
faire la lecture en espérant que vous
soyez au moins plus à l'écoute du
Secours Catholique que des députés de
gauche en 2022 les personnes au chômage
ont veut leur situation se dégrader
notamment avec une baisse de 40 € du
niveau de vie médian mensuel en un an
seulement la réforme de l'assurance
chômage entrée en vigueur en octobre
2021 c'est le Secours Catholique qui le
dit n'y est sans doute pas étrangère
ainsi 24 % des personnes que l'on
rencontre touchent le RSA mais plus d'un
tiers des personnes qui sont éligibles
ne l'ont pas perçu en 2022 contre 29 %
2021 donc il y a une augmentation il est
à craindre que les pressions renforcées
sur les allocataires du RSA je les cite
toujours à sorti de sanctions nouvelles
telle que prévu dans la loi plein emploi
n'aboutissent à éloigner de leur droit
une partacrue des personnes en situation
de
le RSA ne représente plus guerre que 40
% du SMIC contre 50 % à la création du
RMI alors monsieur le ministre si vous
refusez d'écouter les parlementaires si
vous refusez d'écouter le Secours
Catholique peut-être allez-vous entendre
demain les allocataires du RSA de
l'Ardèche que répondrez-vous à Madeleine
lui direz-vous bonjour Madeleine oui
vous avez deux enfants vous vivez à
Tournon vous surviviez jusqu'ici grâce
au revenus de solidarité car l'état
savait que vos vos difficultés devaient
être prises en compte et vous laissez le
temps d'y remédier mais désormais nous
n'avons qu'un seul objectif votre retour
à l'emploi sans conditions comment y
arriverons-nous c'est tout simple un
petit atelier CV un peu de coaching
personnel des Staes d'observation court
dans la logistique à la veille de Noël
non gratifié évidemment bref vous n'avez
pas le temps ah oui parce que vous êtes
une mère seule vos enfants ah oui ils
ont plus de 12 ans ah bah non non non
tant pis vous aurez des sanctions il y a
trop de profiteurs du RSA c'est pas
contre vous Madeleine c'est contre les
autres bon alors peut-être allez-vous
écouter Arnaud de
laamastre bonjour
Arnaud vous étiez travailleur
intermittent de la restauration vous
avez des mots d'eau et la réforme de
l'assurance chômage vous oblige à
reprendre le travail et en plus avec la
réforme des retraites vous allez devoir
travailler de années de plus sans prise
en compte des critères de pénibilité
supprimé là aussi par mon gouvernement
malheureusement vous n'avez plus les
moyens de faire les trajets en voiture
car l'essence est devenu trop cher les
transports sont insuffisants et vous
avez été licencié voulez continuer à
bénéficier du RSA bah impossible parce
que vous ne respectez pas notre cahier
des charges est-ce ça que vous allez
dire sérieusement demain à ces hommes et
à ces femmes nous nous demandons
sérieusement comment on peut réduire ces
parcours de vie déjà si difficile à une
incapacité réelle ou présumée à
l'emploi plutôt que de s'attaquer au
frein connu et répétter que sont la
question des transports la question de
la garde d'enfants la santé plutôt que
mettre les moyens sur
l'insertion vous avez choisi de
continuer de fissurer l'appareil de la
protection sociale qui incombait à
l'état alors Monsieur le Ministre
pendant les débats nous vous avons
demandé une chose un revenu minimum
d'existence pour toutes et tous pour les
accidentés de la vie en en particulier
et aujourd'hui avec cette loi vous le
refusez vous allez plutôt je l'espère
refuser de refuser ce geste
indigne nous avons cherché monsieur le
ministre à discuter du coût réel de
cette réforme et notamment de la
nécessité de mettre les moyens pour
l'insertion mais vous n'avez pas répondu
parce que nous supposons que derrière
cette réforme se cche un objectif celui
de faire des économies en engendrant des
radiations massives du RS
alors je finirai monsieur le ministre
par vous demander une
chose vous avez à partir du 1er janvier
une réforme du ticket resto cette
réforme du ticket resto elle va conduire
simplement à faire que on ne puisse plus
acheter avec son ticket resto des
paquets de patttes et qu'on doiv acheter
des pattes déjà préparées est-ce ça que
vous voulez pour la France Monsieur le
Ministre est-ce que vous viser la
dignité ou est-ce que vous préférez un
texte indigne nous serons contre nous
voons contre j'espère que vous aussi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur François Gernigon pour le
groupe horizon et
[Applaudissements]
apparenté merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le ministre monsieur et madame
le rapporteur mes chers
collègues depuis 2017 l'ambition claire
et résolue de notre majorité a été la
priorité donnée à la politique de
l'emploi aujourd'hui nous sommes invités
à voter pour un texte de loi audacieux
fruit d'un compromis entre députés et
sénateurs et vooté au Sénat jeudi
dernier qui s'inscrit dans une vision à
long terme d'un meilleur service public
pour l'emploi pour tous un dialogue et
d'un accompagnement renforcé et d'une
confiance en nos collectivités
territoriales
précisé regardons les chiffres notre
taux de chômage n'a jamais été aussi bas
depuis 40 ans au 2e trimestre 2023 il
est porté à 7,2 % de la population
active et 1,7 million d'emplois ont été
créés depuis 2017 amenant notre taux
d'emploi au plus haut depuis qu'il est
mesuré par
l'INC cette dynamique est le fruit de
nombreuses réformes de nombreux textes
ambitieux cette tendance à la baisse et
particulièrement notable chez nos jeunes
montrant que cette vision d'un marché du
travail dynamique n'est pas un simple
idéal mais une réalité en construction
avec pour objectif le plein emploi d'ici
2027 le rapport de préfiguration de
France travail nous aait présenté un
tableau qui bien que réaliste interpelle
il mentionne des accompagnements peu
intensifs de suivi tardif voire plus
formel que réel et évoque des actions
peut tourner vers l'emploi ou
l'entreprise
il illustre également à quel point les
parcours peuvent être éclatés et
manquent cruellement de
coordination les entreprises peine à
recruter 18 % des allocataires du RSA N
sont suivis par aucun organisme ce sont
ces constat qui pousse à
l'action c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi
au-delà des chiffres permettra une
transformation profonde avec comme
ambition de renforcer l'accompagnement
vers l'emploi de chacune et chacun tout
particulièrement de ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés du monde
professionnel cet accompagnement se doit
être plus efficace plus tangible plus
personnalisé en facilitant leur
parcours avec la la création de ce rseau
de ce réseau pour l'emploi sera rendu
automatique l'inscription de toutes les
personnes sans emploi dont les
allocataires du RSA et les bénéficiaires
d'un accompagnement de Cap emploi mais
aussi des missions locales lorsque ces
jeunes sont en recherche d'emploi
au-delà de cette simplicité
l'enjeu premier est de garantir un suivi
adapté et continu pour chaque individu
de manière coordonnée le contrat
d'engagement unique vient remplacer la
mosaïque actuelle clarifiant ainsi les
droits et devoirs de chacun sur ce sujet
nous avons collectivement permis
d'inclure une clause pour les 15 heures
d'activité de bénéficiaaires du RSA
s'assurant que sa loi soit adaptée pour
les plus éloignés de l'emploi et les
plus
fragiles il il ne s'agit pas pour les
bénéfici du RSA de donner 15 heur
hebdomadaires mais de pouvoir bénéficier
de 15 he d'accompagnement pour être
accompagné afin de tirer vers le haut et
les sortir de
l'ornière le texte porte également un
ensemble de mesures pour les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
leur taux de chômage est actuellement au
plus bas depuis 8 ans s'établissant à 12
% 2022 c'est une avancée notable
particulièrement en comparaison du taux
de chômage global qui est passé de 8 à 7
% entre juin 2020 21 et juin
2022 mais nous pouvons et nous devons
faire mieux c'est pour cette raison que
ce projet de loi vise également à
renforcer notre dispositif le le titre 3
de ces articles sont spécifiquement
consacrés à faciliter l'insertion
professionnel des travailleurs
handicapés en outre avec ce texte en
consolidant le rôle des missions locales
au sein du réseau France travail nous
permettons de reconnaître et amplifier
le rôle crucial elles sont en premier
ligne pour accompagner nos jeunes
nécessitant un soutien
socio-professionnel il est désormais
précisé dans le texte que tous les
jeunes suivis par les missions local ne
sont pas en attente d'un accompagnement
professionnel et donc n'ont pas tous
vocation à être inscrit à France travail
suite à l'examen en commission enfin
pour éliminer les obstacles
périphériques à l'emploi le texte
établit le service public d'accueil des
jeunes enfants en définissant sa gestion
et son application à l'échelle
territoriale il attribue également aux
communes la responsabilité de cet
accueil
modernise et intensifie le contrôle des
crèches qu'ell soit publique ou privé
adopté au Sénat puis à l'Assemblée le
texte a été le fruit d'un accord
constructif entre les députés et les
sénateurs et a donc été adopté par une
rédaction commune en commission mixte
paritaire le 23 octobre
dernier par un renforcement des droits
et des devoirs de tous ainsi qu'une
réforme d'ampleur de l'ensemble de la
chaîne de prise en charge de demandeur
d'emploi ce texte est équilibré et
permettra de tendre vers le plein emploi
au regard des enje qu'il représente et
de son ambition le groupe horizon et à
parentré soutient ce texte je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame
Marie-Charlotte Garin pour le groupe
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
nupes merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
fruit d'un accord entre les libéraux au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée la loi pleine
emploi que nous votons aujourd'hui
s'inscrit dans la continuité des
offensives de ces dernières années
contre les services public la protection
sociale et les droits des travailleurs
toujours plus loin main dans la main
avec la droite dure hier la case de
l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui le
conditionnement du RSA demain peut-être
la fin de l'aide médicale d'État le
contexte de ce texte la coexistence
d'une pénurie de mains d'œuvre d'un côté
et des personnes sans emploi de l'autre
un peu plus de 350000 emplois vacants
d'un côté 5 millions de chômeurs de
l'autre mais que se passe-t-il que ces
emplois et ces secteurs soient ceux qui
proposent une rémunération faible des
contrats courts et des conditions de
travail souvent difficile ça n'est pas
la question pour vous vous nous proposez
une politique de soi-disant mise au
travail n'importe quel travail n'importe
quelle condition votre méthode rendre la
situation des chômeurs de plus en plus
difficile pour les pousser à reprendre
le plus vite possible un emploi même
s'il n'est pas de bonne qualité ou s'il
ne correspond pas à leurs aspirations on
peut redouter que ça l' pour effet
d'accentuer aussi la crainte parmi les
salariés d'être licencié ou que cela les
décourage de quitter leurs postees mais
là aussi ça n'est pas la question comme
lorsque vous avez cassé l'assurance
chômage ou supprimer l' band de poste
vous confirmez l'ascendant des
employeurs dans le rapport de force
quant à l'amélioration des conditions de
travail c'est là encore un total angle
mort pourtant en mars 2023 44 % des
salariés sont dans un état de détresse
psychologique qui combine la dépression
et l'épuisement et qui peut avoir des
conséquences graves comme l'hypertension
artérielle la dépression et les troubles
anxieux pour cas 14 % d'entre eux la
détresse psychologique est même
qualifiée d'élev et les tr/4 des
salariés interrogés disent que leur état
psychologique est partiellement ou
totalement lié à leur emploi quelle
surprise alors dans le détail finalement
quel changement ah Paul emploi deviendra
France travail mais quelle pépite de
changement alors au-delà du nom et des
millions qui vont être dépensés en
communication pour changer les logos la
philosophie du projet de loi est un
changer toujours plus de coer sur les
usagers des obligations d'inscription à
France travail étendu et un change
profond des métiers d'accompagnement
quels autres changements notables me
demanderez-vous un contrat d'engagement
pour le demandeur d'emploi qui n'est
plus réciproque comme le souhaitai des
députés et les professionnels sur le
terrain alors ça pose la question
suivante est-ce que seules les personnes
au chômages ont des devoirs et l'État je
crois que c'est finalement là le
véritable abandon de poste c'est celui
de l'État qui s'affranchit de ses
obligations envers les chômeurs et les
bénéficiaires du RSA qu'il doit
accompagner dans la même logique la
commission supprimer toute obligation de
France travail que ce soit en terme de
mission et de contrôle des offres alors
exite le droit d'être accueilli informé
orienté et accompagné par le service
public de l'emploi exite le conseiller
référent désigné au sein du service
public de l'emploi exite la possibilité
de l'opérateur de contrôler la légalité
des offres d'emploi que France travail
collecte et publie de même le conseil en
évolution professionnelle toujours
inscrit dans la loi est profondément
remis en cause au profit d'un
accompagnement forcé lié à un minimum de
15 heures d'activité hebdomadaire
conditionnant le versement des
allocations comme le RSA je ne reviens
pas sur cette mesure qui a largement
fait couler l'encre à juste titre tant
elle stigmatise et méconnaît les
allocataire du RSA je me permets
simplement de rappeler ici qu'un quart
d'entre eux sort de ce dispositif au
cours de l'année parce qu'ils obtiennent
un emploi quand d'autres réalise déjà un
travail informel qu'il soit domestique
associatif ou de soins par exemple pour
s'occuper d'un pr âgé ou en situation de
handicap cette mesure touche aussi avant
tout les femmes les personnes seules
avec une personne à charge constituent
32 % de l'ensemble des allocataires du
RSA et il s'agit ultra majoritairement
de mère de famille monoparental mais
comme pour la réforme des retraites
l'égalité c'est sympa pour les fronton
de mairie mais au travail entre les
femmes et les hommes on repassera quant
à l'objectif affiché de permettre à
chacun l'accès à l'autonomie et à la
dignité par le travail et bien
laissez-moi vous dire chers collègues
sans dignité garantie pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA dans leur recherche
et dans leur accompagnement sans salaire
suffisant et sans emploi dans lequel
réellement s'épanouir ça restera une
formule magique qui n'existe pas c'est
un peu comme votre théorie du
ruisselllement c'est C idée que faire
beaucoup de cadeaux plus riches nous
fera bénéficier à tous de leur richesse
à eux ça n'existe pas et si vous pensez
le contraire allez dire ça au tiers des
Français qui se privent de nourriture
faute de moyens aujourd'hui dans notre
pays vous l'aurez compris ce texte issu
du Sénat est encore pire que celui que
nous avions déjà critiqué à l'Assemblée
c'est un texte complètement déséquilibré
fruit d'une vision passéiste du travail
une vision dépassée à contetemps de
l'urgence du moment pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe écologiste votera
contre cette loi je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Yannick Mony pour
le groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
nupes monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente de commission monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre au
lendemain de la réforme des retraites
qui a imposé par 493 2 années
supplémentaires de travail au français
Emmanuel Macron promettait un nouveau
pacte de la vie au travail si un tel
pacte a été conclu ce n'est apparemment
pas avec les travailleurs et les privés
d'emploi le projet de loi pour le plein
emploi sur lequel nous devons nous
prononcer aujourd'hui va en effet rendre
la vie au travail encore plus dure
qu'elle ne l'est déjà les disposition de
ce texte repose d'abord sur une fable
celle d'une inversion de la courbe du
chômage que les derniers chiffres de la
daress démantent tout comme les
projection de l'OFCE et de la Banque de
France qui prévoit une remontée du
chômage jusqu'à presque 8 % des fin
2024 alors oui c'est vrai le taux de
chômage a baissé depuis 2017 mais au
prix de réforme mettant toujours plus à
mal le dialogue social en réduisant
l'accès au droits des demandeurs
d'emploi au prix de radiation toujours
plus importante et qui représente
aujourd'hui une sortie sur 10 des listes
des demandeurs d'emploi au prix de
retour à l'emploi toujours plus précaire
au prix enfin d'une précarisation
toujours plus grande de tous selon ninc
notre pays compte 1,2 million de
travailleurs pauvres 40 des chômeurs
sont pauvres et quand aux allocataires
du RSA auquel votre texte s'en prend
violemment 65 % d'entre eux vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté votre lutte contre
le chômage n'est pas celle que le groupe
des députés communistes et ultramarins
défende celle d'une lutte pour le
travail vecteur d'émancipation de digité
de valorisation et d'unité collective
votre lutte contre le chômage n'est pas
celle qui se place du côté des
aspirations et des besoins des
travailleurs et des privés d'emploi mais
celle qui à l'inverse se tient
résolument du côté du marché du travail
dont les règles sont profondément
inégalitaires et violentes aussi votre
loi pour le plan emploi fait-elle
volontairement l'impasse sur la question
de l'emploi et de sa qualité ce n'est
pas pour rien si pe l'emploi devient
France travail il ne demeure qu'une
injonction travail quel qu'il soit les
taux se resserrant de plus en plus sur
les privés d'emploi et les allocataires
du RSA men àette sanction de plus en
plus rigide d'ailleurs avec votre texte
il n a a plus à proprement parler de
demandeurs d'emploi mais des inscrits
sur la liste des demandeurs d'emploi
jusqu'au conjoint ou concubin d'un
locataire du RSA qu'il soit ou non
disponible pour un emploi tout le monde
est soumis au même contrat d'engagement
dont la CMP a pris soin de supprimer la
notion de réciprocité histoire que
toutes ces femmes et tous ces hommes
n'aient vraiment plus le droit à la
parole mais que vaut un contrat
d'engagement s'il n'est pas
réciproque un régime d'obligation et de
sanction alors qu'il y a aujourd'hui
fois plus de demandeurs d'emploi que
d'emplois disp
votre stratégie vise ainsi et surtout à
rendre invisibles les personnes les plus
en difficulté sociales ou selon vos mots
inemployable et c'est ainsi que vous
baisserez les chiffres du chômage votre
texte enterine aussi l'idée dangereuse
et malsain qu'être privé d'emploi est
une faute et un signe d'oisiveté dans ce
cadre vous avez choisi de suivre la
droite en conditionnant le RSA au moins
à au moins 15 he d'activité par semaine
sans jamais préciser la nature de cette
activité ce faisant vous remettez en
cause frontalement nos principes de
solidarité et vous transformerez le RSA
en une allocation de retour à l'emploi
quand il est une allocation de
subsistance et comme vous n'êtes plus à
une confusion près vous financerez
France travail en fonctionnant indument
lunédique autrement dit en détournant
les cotisations des actifs normalement
destinés à l'assurancielle je ne
m'attarderai pas sur l'article 10
réinttroduit par la CMP qui fait des
communes les autorités organisatrices en
matière d'accueil de la petite enfance
sans leur donner les moyens d'un service
rejoint par là le mauvais scénario du
transfert au département du RSA et quand
on voit ce que devient le RSA avec votre
loi pour le plan emploi on ne peut-être
que très sceptique sur ce qu'il
adviendra d'un service public main de
fois promis de la petite enfance pour
toutes ces raisons monsieur le ministre
entre groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine votera contre ce texte de
régression sociale de lutte acharnée
contre les travailleurs et les privés
d'emploi je vous
remerci merci monsieur le député mes
chers collègues je vouse que sur le vote
du projet de loi je suis saisie par le
groupe Renaissance et le groupe la
France insoumise nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale d'une
demande de scrutin public le scrutin est
annoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin saintthuile pour le groupe
libertin dépendant outreem et
[Applaudissements]
territoire
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues pour atteindre le plein emploi
le gouvernement avait tout tenté et
presque tout réussi si l'on écoute le
récit plus nécessaire de parler de
travail de parler de salaire de
solutions nouvelles non il était temps
de choisir la
facilité t de céder finalement à la
rumeur public au café du commerce au
réseaux sociaux enfin assumer un
discours relayé partout il y aurait des
chômeurs qui préféreraient le confort de
l'assistance le plaisir de loisifeté qui
aurait la précarité heureuse je vous
rassure je vis dans la même France que
vous et j'entends ce discours souvent
répété notre travail c'est d'y apporter
des réponses et plutôt que de corriger
les quelques écueils qui permettent ce
discours plutôt que de traiter les
sujets qui pourrai encourager une forme
d'inactivité en travaillant sur les
reprises d'activité sur la fraude ou
encore sur la question du revenu du
travail vous faites le choix
d'accompagner un discours facile notre
rôle ça n'est pas de choisir
d'accompagner le discours ambiant
lorsquon légifère on le fait avec force
et responsabilité conscient de ce que la
sous-entend pour nos concitoyens vous
faites finalement dans ce texte le choix
de pointer du doigt les chômeurs et
particulièrement les plus fragiles aux
allocataires du RSA vous dites une chose
simple si vous voulez les aides il va
falloir vous bouger accepter
l'inscription automatique condition
cinéquignon du versement de l'aide si
vous voulez les aides vous devrait faire
15 he d'activité qu'importe ce que sera
la définition des 15 heures d'activité
qu'importe qu'elle est du sens ou
qu'elle correspondre au projets
professionnel l'important étant de
rendre un D à la nation parce que vous
qui vivez d'un revenu d'assistance vous
devez quelque chose au pays vous allez
jusqu'à faciliter par un régime de
sanction
revisité vous venez faciliter la
possibilité d'entrevoir une sanction
financière
vous choisissez à défaut d'enrichir les
travailleurs d'appauvrir les chômeurs
cela ne mène nulle part au moment où la
crise du pouvoir d'achat est puissante
au moment où l'inflation est très élevée
votre seule réponse c'est d'envisager de
renier 6 excusez-moi chers collègu si
vous avez pas remarqué chers collègues
il y a un orateur à la tribune qui est
en train de
s'exprimer je suis pas sûr que vous ayez
remarqué
merci de l'écouter allez-y chers
collègues merci madame la Présidente je
ne désespère pas de convaincre les
nouveaux
arrivants vous faites le choix de
revenir sur l'hypothèse de renier 607 €
on est à 300 € en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté ce sont les mêmes que vous
croisez dans vos permanence les mêmes
que vous croisez dans les associations
caritatives les mêmes qui ont besoin du
concours et de distance c'est cela que
vous venez frapper au portefeuille le
groupe lot est attaché au territoire
reconnais les droits et les devoirs
avait fait des propositions construit
sur le mérite avec la possibilité de
bonifier le RSA pour ceux qui
choisiraient un parcours
d'accompagnement renforcé qui le ferait
avec volonté de s'en sortir vous avez
nié ces propositions comme vous avez nié
la possibilité de mettre en place des
sanctions exemplaire qui n'affaiblissent
pas le pouvoir d'achat déjà fragile de
nos concitoyens vous avez refusé toute
proposition qui concern les outr
renvoyant à l'ordonnance vous avez
retiré après la CMP les quelques maigres
amendements que nous avions finalement
réussi à arracher France travail est
devenu ce que nous craignons au départ
un texte de communication politique
creux un texte creux qui flatte les bas
instinct et en choisissant d'accompagner
ce discours vous prenez la direction
dangereuse dangereuse de donner la
possibilité à quelquesuns de faire
croire que parce qu'il y a quelques abus
et quelques écueils que vous ne réglez
pas dans ce texte il faut condamner tout
le monde puisque nous sommes dans un
exercice d'honnêteté intellectuelle nous
relevons avec intérêt le service public
de la petite enfance mais reconnaissons
qu'il est très loin la possibilité de
d'accompagner ce texte de globale les
députés liottes ne le voteront pas déçus
son le fond comme sur la forme et par la
méthode il nous reste du chemin il nous
reste du progrès pour l'instant nous en
sommes loin merci monsieur le
député la discussion générale et clauses
nous en venons au texte de la commission
mixte paritaire conformément à l'article
113 ala 3 du règlement je vais appeler
l'assemblée à statuer d'abord sur les
amendements dont je suis saisie
amendement texte de la cm MP j'ai trois
amendements de coordination monsieur le
ministre oui madame la Présidente
peut-être juste pour pour préciser que
les trois amendements de coordination
ont été vu avec la rapporteur du Sénat
les deux rapporteurs de l'Assemblée ce
sont des corrections de
référence
merci je monsieur le
rapporteur je mets au voix l'amendement
numéro 1 double avis favorable qui est
pour qui est contre il est adopté
amendement numéro 2 même avis même vote
le 3 même avis même
vote je mets au voix le projet de loi
tel qu'il est issu de la commission
mixte paritaire modifié par les
amendements qui viennent d'être
adoptés nous allons procéder au
scrutin merci de regagner vos places le
scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin et
clos le résultat du scrutin votant 342
exprimé 337 majorité 169 pour 190 contre
147 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté